bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j
oggi andiamo avanti su scribblenauts
unlimited prima di cominciare la
gavoglio soltanto dirvi una cosa la
puntata che state vedendo adesso è la
quinta in teoria questa dovrebbe essere
la sesta perché io prima avevo
registrato una puntata che non ho
pubblicato quando l'ho registrata avevo
diciamo mi mancava la voce è come
puntata era uscita un po male quindi ho
deciso di non pubblicarla però state
tranquilli che non vi siete persi nulla
perché se non l'avrei appunto pubblicata
soltanto mi dispiaceva perdere una scena
in particolare di quell'episodio
soltanto una scena che vi faccio vedere
adesso il cosplay era un grandissimo fan
di videogame e di anima tanta stima
fratello che a qualcuno della cultura
nair da qui possa parlare ok ci penso io
perfetto sei contento ha funzionato raga
mi prende per nerd va beh lui sa che
guardo gli anime giustamente scrive
l'ansa a conoscenza del fatto che io
guardo anime c'è raga scribblenauts mida
del nerd c'è neanche mi conosce magari o
magari vede i miei video il gioco
proprio mida del nerd cioè io non so che
cosa dire vabbè sorvoliamo andiamo
avanti allora eravamo rimasti ho fatto
praticamente il carcere niente rica non
c'era nulla di troppo divertente quindi
ripetono vi siete persi nulla allora
direi di andare avanti pianure della
carta ok ci sono iniziamo ad haga non so
che ok
cos'è sta roba benvenuta pianore della
carta grazie mille c'è un pony c'era un
po anni ma che cazzo di livello è questo
siamo in un circo un po scassato ma
siamo in un circo ragazzi e maxwell
paracadutista ti manca il paracadute non
ce l'hai dietro non possa fare uno show
aereo senza qualcosa che vuole allora un
qualcosa di leggero per farlo volare che
ne so io direi di andare sempre sullo
shuttle che mi sembra la scelta più
economica va e scozia
vabbè allora io ho paura ho paura di
andare a vedere che cosa è successo
salve ok c'era lasciato il che passa
ogni tanto perfetto buongiorno senti non
è che mi vai a comprare il latte visto
che sei già in giro perfetto
ok ragazzi che cosa stupida
vabbè ok mentre il nostro amico fa
avanti e indietro direi di andare avanti
chi è questa
pippi calzelunghe questa roba sembra
fresca mi piacerebbe se scoppiasse ok a
sto punto raga un'eruzione vulcanica il
massimo vulcano volano vulcano che cazzo
mamma mia che cosa epica come far
scoppiettare dei pop corn nel modo
giusto allora c'è distretto di polizia a
12 mi manca non l'ho ancora visto
vabbè dai un po anzi teli fatto tutti ok
bene raga siamo arrivati alla st wright
ma prima di farla volevo soltanto perche
c'e una mucca con un cappello da cuoco
perché sto facendo un buon lavoro dammi
una mancia ma che cazzo le mucche che
chiedono la mancia inscrive nov
[Musica]
va bene ragazzi reddito e di iniziare la
sfida con la st wright università degli
scribi out
ok c'è fretta c'è di nuovo freddy
mercury aiuti alla studentessa provare i
risultati ottenuti a farlo entrare nel
college
ok libro di testo non farti beccare però
ok perfetto
ti sei già fatta backup madonna 6 durata
due secondi mio dio ma l'arte del
copiare coop auchan nel sangue tutti i
vestiti della studentessa sono sporchi
che era qualcosa per pulirli ma perché
c'è ma fammi capire ai fatto l'esame di
educazione fisica ti sei rotolate nel
fango che cazzo hai fatto però vabbè
facciamole che ne sono lavatrice
ok raga non ha smesso cos'è una
lavanderia creato una lavatrice mio zio
è ora di testare le sue capacità crea
qualcosa per far sì che la studentessa
acquisisca esperienza lavorativa
un lavoro abbastanza semplice per un
laureando laboratorio scientifico come
ho scritto scritto giusto al primo
tentativo senza neanche guardare che
culo
ok vai lavora lavora maledetta fa
esplodere il mondo con le testate
nucleari chimiche gli esami finali sono
domani aiuta la studentessa studiare
allora l'esame lo devo fare io lo deve
fare lei perché io volevo andare a
giocare videogames per studiare come si
deve a bassa che guarda i video di fa vj
quindi computer e ci siamo mai studia
perfetto i miei video solo istruttivi
ragazzi io errata penso che ogni volta
che qualcuno guarda un mio video un
libro commette un suicidio però va beh
noi prendiamo last rites sono contento
di essere riuscito a farti laureare ok
l'università di scriverlo completato che
è perfetto siamo dei professori provetti
se qualcuno di voi la gaby sogno di
qualcuno che gli faccia ripetizioni non
esitate a contattarmi comunque
proseguiamo allora la mucca col cappello
da cuoco va beh abbiamo capito chi cazzo
è questa sono pronto a lanciarmi con il
paracadute portami in cielo un bel
calcio in culo ci sta che la metà basta
però direi di provare comunque cosa non
può più semplice tra un po trump lo
trampolino ok trampolino a molle
non lo so come cazzo lo volevi sono ma è
ovvio che cazzo è successo mio zio
[Musica]
la pensiamo
la gravità secondo scrive nout c'è
allora adesso me lo spiegate come fa
oggi è tornata e tornata red bull
stratos scribblenauts version
allora adesso mi spiegate come un
trampolino che rimbalza sulla testa
possa sparare a 3.000 metri di altezza
una persona io non me lo spiego però
spero che tu sia contenta perché c'è un
bicchiere d'acqua qui riempie di quel
pop corn hanno riempito va bene ok raga
devo andare lì sopra perché avevo visto
un pony prima soltanto che non so come
salire non c'è una maledetta scala devo
proprio ferma che ho bisogno dello
shuttle
ok però [ __ ] bene ok ci siamo
buongiorno farmi sembrare eccezionale in
modo da attirare un pubblico per il mio
numero
gere è che un sombrero e quello che fa
al caso tuo vai attira addio si è
suicidato
si è buttato nel bicchiere si è buttato
nel bicchiere in mezzo ai pop corn che
avevo messo prima dentro in questo
momento c'è un bicchiere che salta con
all'interno dei pop corn e un cavallo
col sombrero questo è scrive lo zar
limited giusto perché seduto sulla mia
testa ha cortesemente potrebbe levarsi
dai [ __ ]
no perché non è tanto perfetta grazie
allora è oddio mio dio santissimo ma sto
cazzo di trampolino e massimo
se fai
ma che cazzo raga io me ne vado basta
basta ma io sto io ho più giocato
videogame più non capisco più un cazzo
quindi laga prima me ne vado e meglio è
rovine di ellissi ok perfetto entriamo
qui non so che cos'è
non ne ho la più pallida idea ci sono i
gorilla c'è una cassa toracica ma che ma
che minchia bokeh i csv roth cefiro di
final fantasy e ceo willie wonka signor
willy wonka mi dica che quelli
innaffiatoi alla menta questa pianta
carnivora può curare molte malattie ma
non riesco a farla crescere allora
fertilizzante ok ci mettono re a
scrivere la innaffiatoio gigante ok ci
siamo ci penso io provi a voglio vedere
come fa a non crescere con questo perché
cazzo mi sono scoppiato direi di provare
quella starai draga
no ho sbagliato a cliccare perfetto
scrive quest ok inizia non ho idea di
che cosa sia sinceramente c'è un elmo
non vedo neanche dove sto andando che i
cer culés prepara gli avventurieri per
una ricerca epica dal guerriero un'arma
ok tu sei hercules veramente allora io
direi una spada gommosa c'è c'è
o mio dio una spada gommosa raga e tipo
gli orsacchiotti gommosi le caramelle
ok ma brigante piace stare foglio alla
mischia ok maleducato non si parla bocca
piena
va bene dato che sei d'artagnan direi di
fare un qualcosa inerente più o meno
alla tua epoca
quindi direi che un mitragliatore e
perfetto mitagliatrice medio va e non
l'ho data a lui a prefetto ripresa
ebbene buongiorno anche lei lo stregone
un maestro di mancino a dargli un arma
che permetta di sfruttare i suoi poteri
allora
ma non ha fatto niente magia let there
be light
ok la guaritrice ha bisogno
ab la guaritrice un ruolo di supporto
dalle qualcosa per guarire gli altri
membri del gruppo a sei un healer allora
facciamo medicina perfetto vai a curare
gli altri con la medicina perfetto
allora un arco gommoso un mitragliatore
per do tania weber be light per il mago
e poi una medicina per la tipa dietro
perfetto intanto c'è da un fossero da
giusta va tutto secondo me un meteorite
minchia me la devi insegnare questa non
la sapevo
beh mi sta facendo il culo ragazzi mi
sta facendo
no o mio dio ma perfetto civile
[Risate]
ma che cazzo stanno mi copiano le
tattiche il bazooka la mia tattica
bastardi
adesso voglio una parte del trofeo
brutti stronzi andiamo andiamo avanti
c'è allora la squadra me l'ha fatto io è
perfetto nola strike l'ho presa mi ero
dimenticato di prenderla st wright
scrive questo è completato totale
straight 22 rega guai a chi lo nega ma
scribblenauts è veramente uno dei giochi
più divertenti che abbia mai giocato
finirà di sicuro senza ombra di dubbio
in una mia futura top ten perché
veramente etico va bene raga direi di
proseguire c'è una via da destra cascate
di spadafora c'è di nuovo freddy mercury
ma qua ci eravamo già stati comunque
tranne di sopra di sopra non c'era
ancora andato ma preferirei che in ogni
episodio io facessi delle zone sempre
diverse perché fare sempre le stesse
zone secondo me dopo un po anno a
iachini magari se verso la fine quando
finirò gioco volete che io continui a
fare gli episodi speciali magari
riprenderò delle sfide che non ho fatto
ma nel frattempo mentre la serie
continua di ray di cercare zone che non
ho ancora fatto allora palude del
pallino raga faccio l'ultima sfida e poi
chiudo qui l'episodio perché sennò è
diciamoci prolunghiamo troppo allora
palù delle pallino chi è questo devo
veramente andare ma questo posto è
veramente sporco allora è
salve se qualcuno sta cagando lì dentro
c'è uno fuori che aspetta brutto stronzo
lo sciacquone non funziona allora io non
ti consiglio di andare anche se sporco
perché non funziona lo sciacquone però
dammi un allora dammi un panno e te lo
pulisco io fanno tessuto ok no non lo
facevo io brutto stronzo se ti devo fare
io i favori se chiedi un favore follo
fare a meno nate non molto igienico non
mi dire che è cagato lì dentro c'è
dentro il panno
senti non voglio saperlo io proseguo say
that would quello di ion vuole qualcosa
per caso se cosa vuoi allontana da me
questi picchi hai unito in testa se non
te ne sei accordo allora vengo io
andiamo conquistiamo allora brutti scanu
si dovette andarmene andate a cercare un
altro nido brutti stronzi che ci sono io
devo provare il mio uomo in pace brutti
bastardi dovete andare allora
fucile da cecchino allora se qualcuno ha
rapito tre secondi a perfetto se ne sono
andate allora se ne sono andati o che ha
funzionato la minaccia è bene minacciare
dei picchi con un fucile da cecchino non
è una cosa che faccio di solito ma ha
dato che ci siamo andiamo con nostra mi
cosa c'è una bambola voodoo che non so
che cosa mi serve ma la raccolgo a sto
punto vai
ok per caso tuo perché c'è un ufo che
cazzo succede
vuoi qualcosa per forza perché non
avrebbero mai messo un ufo e senti un
secondo facciamo volante volante e anche
veloce possibilmente perché vai lento
come mia nonna è ok
come non detto sto volando in una
maniera idiota
buongiorno a lei darci quello che
vogliamo e vi lasceremo in pace si una
torta in faccia telefono telefono
elettronica ok vai telefono a casa
no non ha funzionato perfetto darci
quello che vogliamo rilasciare mi pace
che cazzo ne so la terra corpo celeste
vai
gli ho dato il nostro pianeta e se n'è
andato perfetto lo ricordavo un po più
grande ma son dettagli raga va bene dai
direi che forse si sta prolungando un po
troppo l'episodio quindi non faccio in
tempo a fare la sfida della st wright
però dal prossimo episodio riparte dalla
sfida della st wright e se la finisco
dovremmo riuscire a sbloccarci la parte
nuova la nuova zona che non socie
l'everest c'è un parco giochi nell'acqua
quando riuscirò a prendere la st wright
appunto direi che per questo episodio
possa concludere qui se vi è piaciuto il
video come al solito lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina
facebook che come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione affanculo il
telecomando ogni volta se non sei da
quelli siti iscrivetevi né ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi